こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
やってまいりましたー後輩に仕掛けるドッキリシリーズ
まさきに仕掛けるシリーズは大抵ばれてます
私もバレてると思ってます
視聴者さんの皆さんもバレてると思ってます
で、まさき自身もバレてると思ってます
もうなんかね、バレすぎてて、もうなんか
ドッキリみたいなエンターテイナーになってて
それじゃあダメなんすよ
ドッキリてのはやっぱこう
知らないから起きるっていう面白さがドッキリだと思うんで
テクニカルな方法でまさきをドッキリに仕掛けていこうかと思います
今回見つけたのはコチラ
もう、どこから見つけてくるんだろう俺これ
電流が流れるホッチキスでございます
ホッチキスで電流が流れる系は今まで見たことないので
これはNEWタイプでございます
さすがにホッチキスで流れるとは思わないっすよ
うわあ怖い怖い怖い
もう、パッと見は完全ホッチキスですね
うわ、よくできてるな
完全にホッチキス
ていうかホッチキスじゃね？
おそらく、ギミックとしてはここですね
ここの鉄の部分を握って
で、バシンとやると電流が流れると。
NWEシステムでございます
僕は仕掛ける側の責任者として
これの電流の強さを知っとかなければいけません
あーもうこれ本当にいやなんだよ
一回喰らわなければいけないんですよ
うわ怖
ホッチキスってなんか嫌だ
握る感じがすごい嫌だ
いきますいきますいきますよ
いきますよ
あっあーいやだいやだいやだ
いきますいきますいきますよ
あーー怖いよ！
やだやだ本当に嫌だ
本当にやだやだ
いきますいきますいきますよ
はっはっはっ
あーあーふっっっふっふっふっ
待って、落としちゃった
落としちゃったから、壊れてないか、もう一回確かめなきゃ
あーー痛いッ！
うあああああああううう
強いっす今回
やばいやばい
良いよ良いよ（いいよこいよ！）
良いの来たよ
というわけで今回はですね
僕一人でこういうの仕掛けるともう
完全にバレちゃうので
今回はですね
なんと、UUUMの社員さんに来ていただきました
どうぞー
もう多分、僕が仕掛けても、まさきにバレちゃうので
UUUMの社員さんと僕で
なにか資料を作ってきたんで
社員さんも忙しくて資料作ってるから
それをホッチキスで止める手伝いをしてくれという
触ってみてくださいよ
社員：え、いいすよｗ
そのまま
社員：これやばっ！
社員：やばい
結構笑えないレベルで強いよ
今回、社員さんと僕用の別の
ホッチキスを準備しました
僕と社員さんでこうやってハンガーで
紙を持ってきますね
すごい真面目に資料作ってる感を出しました
こうやって紙を準備して
すごい真面目にこうなんか
3枚ずつで止めてみたいな
「まさきごめんホッチキスで止めて」って言って
これを渡して
バチコンでそのまま
という感じでございます
これ多分引っかかると思います
社員：なるほど
カメラがバレないのと
あと、UUUMの社員さんを使ってるという
この2つが整った時多分
本当に信じ切って
いくと思うので
では早速いってみよう
なんで白紙かって言われると
UUUMの
まだ小さいクリエイターさん
子供のクリエイターさんとかに絵とか好きなこと描かせて
社員：おお、なるほど
想像力を膨らませるための白紙の3枚が必要だから
社員：あ、今　はじめさん手が離せないみたいなので
社員：今出ますので
ガちっぽいな＾～
( ^)o(^ )
俺、UUUMとやんなきゃいけないことがあって
この紙をですね
まとめてほしいんですよ
はじめ：面倒臭いっすー
（笑）
社員：じゃあ二人でやろうかって話なんですけど
3枚
（えぇ自分でホッチキス持ってるんかーい）
（やばい、予想外すぎる）
（なぜ23歳男性が俺の家に遊びに来るときに）
（ホッチキスを持ち込んでいるんだ）
（いや、今はそんなことどうでもいい）
（今ならまだ間に合う）
はじめ：ホッチキスあるよ
（八ーはッHAHAHA）
（馬鹿めー）
（引っかかったなまさきー）
（貴様はもはや俺の手のひらで踊る操り人形）
（てめーの命も時間の問題だ）
社員：どうぞ、これで
社員：ぱちっとやってもらって
社員：3枚ずつ
社員：これもう3枚になってるので
まさき：大丈夫？
社員：これあのぉUUUMの資料で
今度子供たちにそれに絵を描いてもらおうっていう、なので今日中に
資料作らなきゃいけないんですよ
まさき：はぁはぁ
うええうぇへっへｗ
まさき：信用してないぞ俺は
（電流が流れる）うわあああ
～＾ED＾～
うわあああ×∞
ででででん
うわあああ！！！
はじめ：見た瞬間分かった？
だって、こんな都合よく持つとこだけ、こんな電気通りそうな
はじめ：おかしいなぁ～ばれないと思ったんだけどなー
まさき：何を（ry
あぶるべえいじるｒ